Affinity chromatography is one type of
chromatography where the separation
happens based on molecular affinity
in this chromatographic method Affinity
column is packed with beads and each of
these beads are tagged with affinity
material many of the cases these
Affinity material could be antibody or
other type of tags
so the first step is basically
introduction of the protein with this
particular bead and this Affinity step
is the most important aspect of these
separation
it's important to know that non-specific
protein would not bind to the Affinity
tags
so the first step is loading of the
protein mixture then binding happens
with the specific protein with the
Affinity tag and later on washing step
get rid of all type of non-specific
interactions later on with the illusion
buffer the protein of interest is eluted
and this is how we get purified protein